what's up reject ville of the smanos I'm
confusing you attention
I'm Greg Alba here with me is Danny unbe
hey Danny and Shane you might know him
from his channel called Danny unchain
where he also does reactions this mother
fudger is visiting from New York City
he's a tough guy he's a tough cookie
this one keep trying to kick my ass and
eat some pizza kid he's a cliche New
Yorker nothing beyond that really what I
like humor me like I know he does a liar
any dates Puerto Rican Italian Irish
woman because he's in New York
hey you like the movie aliens right yes
well Danny Unchained honest trailers for
aliens this year's palette of life that
was a lot you don't like the moon I
don't like new and whoa this is your
first video with us you're gonna sit
here and tell me you don't like aliens
yeah
the worst one what did we talk about
between meeting subscribers halfway why
that's all right if you don't like the
movie aliens movies are subjective go on
daily
mic so on from James Cameron before he
got obsessed with blue people ponytail
zags comes a brilliantly simple plan to
make alien even better conveyed his
Laurel hahaha
aliens people you see this equal to
whatever Prometheus was about did a
sequel that wasn't necessarily better
than the original but a damn sure was
bigger Gilyard
[Music]
more baby
[Music]
you know there's work that they twisted
a horror film into a war movie
but every other action franchise just
figured good secret meetings Wow
[Music]
return to the cry be sweaty truck stop
bathroom that is the alien universe
nobody touch nothing and dust off your
undies just a leave your dad's first
crush Ripley she's back again after
taking out an alien single anyway and
still no one this is too a thing she has
to say I'm telling you the first thing -
thank you also Raffaella will you
listening listen to me just one of those
things managed to wipe out my entire
crew yeah okay right do it now Ridley's
download she's writing with the colonial
Space Marines they may not be all that
brave not that in shape don't have the
best discipline and are more than a
little bit creepy sometimes there's some
juicy colonists daughters we have to
rescue from their virginity okay but
that big gutters breeze we have weak
side up soon rise above being disposable
alien vents like eggs the grease faded
soldier at all your favorite movies
Vasquez of master of disguise cleverly
pretending to be latina function
available that's hard same person right
because it the Marine we really can't
even get me out how did they cut the
power man they're in our deal you're not
going to last 17 hours game over man
game over
RIPD packs it's never game over man
together they'll take on the nastiest
monster and the galaxy corporate middle
managers this installation has a
substantial dollar value attached to it
and also some Xena Wars perfect killing
machines who can only be defeated by big
as futuristic go ahead
brat assault rifles fire Tania shotguns
and guys for extra slow robot budgets
but maybe they look scary it's like a
sex toy factory made out of scorpions so
strapped in with one of the greatest
sci-fi movies of all time that took all
the cool stuff from the original like
crawling through Doug's milky robots
and the exact same ending then added
freaking backs and a Batmobile because
even if you're making a brutally dark
Syfy movie for adults you still gotta
sell a few toys marine diving is me oh
hi better story that prometheus story
the talented Ellen Ripley hey it's you
sulfide the garbage pail kid mad about
you Adam I know the taxman be up up that
up I see creepy oh hi favorite twist
channel yeah we had the most badass
moment inside by history get away from
her you best aliens
yep that actually sums it up pretty good
Ripley I got one question for you water
duh compiler coming over man game over
oh really yeah how are you come with
that your gun power comes from lying he
may add that your father boy but he
wasn't your day Norman Reedus is my
husband he just doesn't know it yet
waffles are just pancakes with all right
three jockeys man honest trailer screen
junkies is my favorite YouTube channel
that's for damn sure
more than yours probably just letting
you know that
I think we should make okay I'm going to
a video though I had no idea how to
remember her name the one who plays bass
cast the Latina soldier in here I had no
idea that she was that person in Titanic
looking at that footage I was tripping
me out so much I think I noticed the guy
who played in hitman that same guy can
hit man the new original the original
hit man yeah what's the original head
man you mean like the one based on the
video game yeah you saw that I know
nothing no because that was words
Michael Biehn being in like all those of
the do to the soldier pay with me raw
Terminator aliens the other one though
is Bill Paxton Bill Paxton rest in peace
yeah Bill Paxton was killed by a
terminator was killed by the aliens was
a grenade explosion but he died in
aliens me spoiler if you haven't seen
EMP also was killed by a predator hmm
then predator to Bill Paxton is the main
connecting tissue to Holly's I don't
think he should have been the one an
alien vs. predator because he's the one
who connects all these people movie
sucked on which one alien versus
Predator in Baltimore you're wrong I
think they're way better than any of
these aliens I think it goes ABP requiem
number one number two is prometheus
number three is alien versus Predator
than resurrection than alien 3 and then
at the bottom is like aliens and alien
you're going out to sit in direction
here no I mean 100% truthful I don't
[ __ ] on this channel this is all
true they're all amazing and the other
thing too I noticed is the crew when
they were talking about them and Alec
they they're out of shape and they're
kind of not a control tool and they're
kind of perverted the kind of creepy I
was like I forgot that this crew was
kind of a turn-off in the beginning okay
doubt like I thought I love the crew I
love the soldiers and then I forgot that
oh yeah because we're kind of like not
the most appealing group of soldiers
when you first meet them okay I don't
even look like they can really protect
you they just have like these big-ass
guns
you can manually operate you know yeah
that's badass right there that's Danny
and Shane motion inspection yeah Michael
Baisden are their water select movie
aliens look at Michael fatigue that's
not a minion yes you know when you drink
tea you like it and if I don't this tea
and I didn't like it
well what didn't you like about it
everything really really everything this
is breaking my heart Danny unchain the
cheesiness of like the acting the
cheesiness the way they like with the
things going out of stomach the faint
screams I don't know at the time seems
like it's okay based off how because the
kind of minor feedback you gave me Oh
like a lien here's what I'm conclude a
Liam one is rather this rather grounded
space movie that really takes his time
is super slow it's not loaded with alien
action throughout not loaded with chest
bursting and whatever here it's like oh
that's rocket rule alien I don't know I
still thought it was intense and
suspenseful and exciting it's totally
very different I thought it worked
are you being this way we're supposed to
be friends it come from New York to
California just just to talk [ __ ] with
me about aliens is that what you're
doing Danny the first movies my mine
it's great well we're not talking about
the first movie right now what do you
think of alien 3 never watched it you're
an interesting character you know that's
it
I heard bad things about us I didn't
watch it well watch you just form your
own opinion because it's the best alien
movie hands down that and resurrection
like I said earlier those are the better
twenties length no I'm not much of a
liar I am a manipulator and I lie but
I'm not a liar oh and those are the
shoes you can buy those shoes now right
they have the Reebok shoes and they have
like a xenomorph stop or one video
actually yeah I think you look sick and
those shoes he come in Congress does it
come in black wait I think that'd be
pretty cool
together I love that bit about my
favorite twitch channel we might be
starting to twitch really yeah to do it
I'm going to livestream all the time
but I go poop yeah there's me taking
crap yeah I hope everybody if you if you
tip $5 I'll go again okay then I can
control my vowel like no one's business
this is how you make yourself attractive
on the internet Danny I'm teaching you
some tips if you want to get your
channel bigger right talk about pooping
I'll get Charlie stuck in the hole don't
get trying to look in this way all right
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
wait we recently watched the patreon go
over there check out all the exclusive
perks you can get a t-shirt maybe you
can only have a Google hangout coming up
this week we got exclusive videos on
there we got deleted tick oh my god so
much on the pot three on people are
loving it I'm loving it Danny Unchained
is Danny Unchained reactions videos and
other talking videos on the Danny
unchain channel go over there check him
out
laugh with him love with him touch
yourself in yeah you don't think I do
that good and I watch your videos good
you don't think I'd do that I love it if
you do that then it's good order let's
make out Wow